[Music]
well it's been quite a year and I don't
think I'm being excessively gloomy in
saying that it's been a year in which
lots of rather bad things have happened
we've had war in Ukraine
we've had a lot of economic anxiety and
rampant inflation
uh we have had strikes breaking out
everywhere
um Andrew if I may start with you uh a
lot of people compare it to the 1970s
and the winter of discontent do you
think such talk is exaggerated
uh yes the only people who are comparing
it to the 1970s and never lived through
the 1970s and you you just have to look
at a chart of strikes just to take one
metric uh and Strikes in the 70s they're
massive compared to now I mean it is
true that we're in probably the most
strikes in 10 years uh though we've yet
to reach a stage where any of these
Strikers really win and I noticed that
even Mr Lynch of the rmt is getting
increasingly irascible in broadcast
interviews which suggest to me that he
thinks he's going to lose now I did warn
him in July of this year that he didn't
have the power he thought he had that
working from home had changed all that
and that the rails were not as essential
as before so yeah it's been a pretty
Grim year I agree with that but it's
nothing like the 70s in Britain we've
not had to call in the IMF whereas we
did in the 70s there aren't strikes
every day and the unions win every
strike which happened in the 70s that's
not happening inflation has not reached
25 which it did in the 1970s even though
it's high and interest rates last time I
looked at Stillwater around two percent
two and a half percent whereas uh then
in these days there were over 20 so you
know and Jimmy Carter had just come down
from the mountain known as Camp David to
say that America was a grouped in a
malaise America has a lot of pro
problems but it's not quite a malays at
the moment so it's not it's difficult
it's tough it's tough for people to live
through these times it's a difficult
compared to Years Gone by and I think I
I would also I think the reason why it
seems
so Grim is that this was really meant to
be the year where we we on both sides of
the Atlantic we boomed back from the
pandemic it was to be back to normality
growth would return Prosperity would
return and the combination of the war in
Ukraine and inflation uh which are
linked
um has meant that we've not boomed back
at all in fact we're kind of treading
water
Lionel do you think um our industry the
media I know you're a novelist but you
also do with the media
um uh do you think we're to blame
slightly for creating this climate of uh
Gloom I mean I keep reading about
General strikes and there's never hasn't
been a general strike since 1926 I think
uh and there's this sort of sense that
actually is it really a general stroke
because actually as Andrew says it's not
really in the same sense
um are we journalists to blame for
creating this climate of of despair
I think that might be giving journalists
a little too much I mean everything that
we're talking about is real
and not the invention of the media
and
there even if the strikes are not as
terrible as they were in the 1970s
um what is driving the strikes is is
substantial I mean it's uh for one thing
it's the consequence of of the lockdown
policies and the extravagant amounts of
money we spent on absolutely nothing
during that period
and it seemed at first as if we were
going to get away with it and that it
was like oh that that's fine the
economy's bounced right back and and
there was nothing wrong with having that
response to covet because because we
haven't suffered any consequences and
then it well it because economics is a
slow lumbering beast and it you know the
the results take a while to show up and
they're showing up
um there's a way in which the war in
Ukraine is is doing politicians a favor
because it helps disguise the fact that
a lot of this inflation is
um not uh due to Russia's Invasion but
it is due to the excesses of pandemic
response and
um you can see that in the the
creeping up of inflation well before
February 24th
Andrew I take Lionel's point that
journalists probably shouldn't
exaggerate uh how important we are in
the world but perhaps what I was getting
is maybe social media uh since everyone
is a journalist in a way on social media
uh and that contributes Twitter in
particular to a kind of Hysteria about
things and a lack of a sense of
perspective
yes I mean I think you know we
journalists we do like bad news uh
because for some reason we think it
sells uh or maybe it's just more
dramatic than good news uh and uh and
social media
has that in Spades I mean it amplifies
bad news no one on social media or very
few people actually tweet good news
there is one web there is one uh Twitter
feed uh in Britain which does announce
Jefferson I think is called announces
you know new investments in British
industry and uh new infrastructure and
so on it's like a lone voice it's a one
little ray of sunshine in a whole
Twitter feed of misery uh there and I
think that has helped to amplify there
is also a a particularly British
characteristic of work here it's not
true where I am at the moment on the
American side of the Atlantic which is
that there's a whole industry in Britain
doing ourselves down
uh indeed there are some people are
never happy unless they're doing
ourselves down unless they're doing the
country down and I think the whole
brexit debate made that worse because
the the remainers
um they want to be Vindicated in the
stands they took and they want the
breakfast tears to be proved wrong and
so much is still seen through this prism
of remain or leave and they want Britain
to fail because that will vindicate the
decision they took to vote not to leave
and show that all these brexiteers were
wrong and what they did so that's added
to the the general predisposition of the
British chattering classes to do the
country down
well Andrew I'll stay with you you are
in New York at the moment uh the latest
economic news for America seems to be a
little bit uh more cheerful uh inflation
seems to be coming down uh do you get a
sense that uh that can do American
Spirit is still there and they feel that
next year is going to be a a year in
which America bounces back
the can-do speed
up where I am it's not in New York I
mean New York is a shadow of its former
self at the moment it's a part of it
like a shanty town it's quite you know
it's a city I love and I've been coming
here and living here over and on since
1976 and it's back to the segment we
talked about the 70s New York in many
ways is back to the 70s it's dilapidated
It's Shabby he's got people shouting at
you in the streets it's got a
threatening sense to it again crime is
Right Rising the place is filthy retail
stores are closed I mean I'm not in
exactly the poorest part of New York I'm
in Midtown and I just need to go up to
2nd Avenue and every second retail unit
is closed I mean you the contrast with
London is quite dramatic I mean you in
London now you almost really wouldn't
know there had been a pandemic uh London
is just kind of back to normal now New
York is not back to normal at all and
blues to me it will be it's actually got
more decline in it before we get back to
that that but as we all know New York is
not America and other parts of America
are doing well outside the big cities
the country is coming back and I think
as always you know new America was kind
of first into this recession I don't
think the recession will be very deep
and it will be first out inflation is
beginning to come down there's been a
huge you add Mr Trump and Mr Biden
together there's been an incredible
amount of Keynesian pump priming which
contributed as like I was saying to
inflation you can't blame it all in the
uh the war that's for sure uh in Ukraine
um but I do think America will come out
of it uh more quickly and help to drag
up the rest of the world economy because
where else where else are we going to
get this growth it ain't coming from
Europe that's for sure Europe is adding
for a serious recession China is in its
94th lockdown
um and actually its economy is really
stuttering now you can forget get all
predictions that China will overtake the
American economy in this decade in size
that ain't going to happen so I think
it's good that America will begin to get
its act together again
let's keep with America but move to
politics uh the last time I think I
spoke to you on spectator TV was after
the midterms and you were in quite a
good mood because uh not just because
the Red Wave hadn't happened but because
uh trumpist candidates as many people
have noticed got defeated all the Senate
candidates in particular were defeated
uh does that give you calls for optimism
in 2023 that uh certainly the American
right might return to something you
regard more as sanity
well the statistics would not bear that
out
not yet you know
if you look at the polls of Republican
voters the majority of them still
support Trump and the real question is
whether or not they come to their senses
in time and there's not very much time
left uh
a year from now
I think that the party has to have some
sense of resolution about which
direction they're going and what's
really frustrating is that you know they
have they have a wide open door in the
White House the the Republicans could
simply walk away with the executive
branch
in 24 if they just ran someone who
wasn't Trump
the the this Trump thing is is a
drive to self-destruction and
um
I
honestly I am certain DeSantis could do
it there are probably a number of
candidates who can do it I think that
DeSantis is probably the the best bet
but I feel that there's a funny kind of
clock ticking little by little
uh Trump supporters are somewhat reduced
in number and nothing happens in the
news in relation to that guy that would
you would think increase his support
aside from of this whole persecution
problem and that's that's one thing that
he's capitalizing on now so that despite
the fact that he's a former president of
the United States he's running as an
underdog
and that that
you know that plays into the natural
paranoia of his supporters because they
they do think that the world is against
them and that
um most of what's most of Trump's
Shenanigans are due to you know the FBI
and every other deep State organization
coming after him
um
you know I I I I I don't personally as a
former Biden voter it looks you know I
don't want him to run again I don't want
and that's true that makes me like the
majority of the country it's something
like three quarters of American voters
say they don't want either one of those
two elderly gentlemen to be running
again and I you know I have
tremendous concerns about Biden's uh
mental facilities and they're certainly
not going to be getting any better by
the time he's 86.
I
I had concerns about Trump and and just
how much he may have deteriorated
because if you look at earlier
recordings of trump when he was younger
he was far more articulate he spoke in
complete sentences and he didn't use the
same word over and over again it uh he
himself has also degenerated and you
know it's a big country and we can do
better
but uh you know it is not impossible
from this perspective that we end up
with another Trump Biden
election in 24 and
what's wrong with us
well let's cross back uh across the
Atlantic and talk about Westminster
because after all London we've had a
pretty crazy year in British politics
too we've had uh three prime ministers
we've lost count of how many chances so
much so that at The Spectator Awards
recently our parliamentarian Awards we
had a chancellor of the year uh award
um I wonder to you uh probably a bit of
a silly question but um which politics
seems crazier uh to you as an American
in Britain British or American
I'm sorry I really have to opt for the
Americans everything
I was hoping that that would push us
towards the conversation about Britain
but okay we're going back to America I I
the shenanigans in the UK are on a
completely different and I have to say
lesser scale it's it's
not of great consequence in in the big
picture and even the uh markets
overreaction towards trust uh that has
settled down and I don't think it has
had huge long-term uh consequences those
interest rates were going up anyway
so uh I I think that on on the level of
crazy we have you beat it's you don't
have anyone uh like Trump in the wings
threatening to take over the country
everyone is relatively credible
that's that's no doubt true but uh
Andrew I mean that it hasn't been a good
year for the Tory party I think that's a
fair thing to say We'll file that we'll
file that under British understatement
so uh I think um I mean can Rishi sunak
turn it around for the Tory party or is
Labor's lead now unassailable going into
the next general election
there's an outside chance he can turn
around I don't think you can count that
out the country's not actually actually
gagging for Kia St Arma
um but it's probably not likely that he
wins the election so much as the Tories
lose it uh so he could turn it around if
he can get into if we can get out of the
recession get on top of inflation get
some growth back living standards Rising
again get out of this cost of living
crisis then I wouldn't count count it
out but there is a mountain to climb I
mean it's perfectly possible in
retrospect that uh historians will say
2022 was the year the Tories lost the
election uh you know because they've
just been self-indulgent and concerned
with their own internal tribal divisions
and they seem to have lost any purpose
for governing the country you know what
what's the purpose of a touring
government now uh except to do lots of
non-tory things like raise taxes to the
highest level in 70 years it seems like
a government
this just got to run out of steam and
and even a new leader like Mr sunac who
is bright and uh has lots of attractions
I think you know he seems to be he's a
bright guy he seems a nice guy but he's
yet to give them a sense of purpose he's
yet to reinvigorate the government which
new leaders can do I mean even John
Major not exactly the most invigorating
character
taking over from Margaret Thatcher he
did invigorate the Tories by enough uh
to win the 1992 election but there's no
sign that Mr sunac does that yet I'm I
remember in 1979 after uh five years of
uh rather desolatory labor government
Jim Callaghan who was the Prime Minister
and he was up against Margaret Thatcher
in the spring of 79 or early summer of
79 and as people were debating in his
inner circle could he beat Thatcher the
polls were not that much against him he
said there just comes a time when the
the whole atmosphere turns against you
that when the just the the climate is
against you it doesn't matter what you
do you're not going to win that turned
out to be true in 79 it was definitely
true in 97 when John Major lost by a
landslide to Tony Blair the danger for
the Tories is it's now true for Mr
sunac's stories
a lot of people saying Andrew that um
you know uh reformist party the Reform
Party populist parties on the right may
now have a Resurgence because brexit had
sort of shot the ukip fox but now
um an angry right is re-emerging do you
see signs of that no I don't actually uh
I don't see signs of that and I think
it's wishful thinking on the Hardline
brexiteers
um I'm also not sure that Mr farage
wants to leave his rather comfortable
perch in a 24-hour news station which
earns him a lot of money to go and do
that I don't see any I think beyond the
sort of square mile where you are
Freddie nobody wants to relitigate that
referendum nobody wants to go back
through the brexit the remainder leave
arguments most people just for good or
ill they just want to move on the cards
have the LIE where they lie and we just
need to get on with it and interesting
that is the view of kirst armor as well
he doesn't want to breathe there are
people around him would love to do it
he's not going to do it so I think no
the the Reform Party is not going to
have a demonstrable influence on British
politics uh that it hopes it it might
have I think it's back in England at
least it's back to labor conservative
even the lib Dems really don't seem to
be making much of a breakthrough because
Mr starmer has made it possible for lib
damn minded people to vote labor again
they don't need to vote for the leader
of the liberal Democrats who I can just
remember Mr Davey
um and what are the interesting things
too is that if it is time if it's
Labor's turn again
that cauterizes Sidelines the whole
Scottish separatist movement
because it is much harder to run a
separatist campaign against the labor
government in London than a conservative
government in London so you know I think
there are
quite big changes uh quite Watershed
events about to happen in Britain as a
result of the way things are at the the
moment I would say it's
three four to one against the Tories
winning the next election but
we know things can change and you know
we live in you know who would have seen
the Ukraine war coming I mean I was very
optimistic about the economy of this
year but on both sides of the Atlantic I
saw growth returning investment
returning and all the rest of it and it
Lionel's right inflation was starting to
rise the central banks made a terrible
call uh on that and we've all suffered
for that but I still thought there would
be some growth and I never saw the
Ukraine war there are just what was it
Don rumsfels said I think that was one
of these unknown unknowns yeah
let us wrap this up uh if I may
uh on on an attempt at a more cheerful
note because Christmas is supposed to be
a source of uh optimism for Humanity
uh Andrew uh in our Christmas edition uh
I'll start with you Andrew in our
Christmas edition we ask various
contributors including uh the Dalai Lama
amazingly enough uh if uh what gives
them hope
um so I wonder Andrew going into 2023
what gives you hope
well I don't know what the Dalai Lama
said but whatever he said I agree with
I've interviewed him he's the most
impressive person I've ever interviewed
uh and you're speaking to the least
spiritual person in the world here
um listen I here's the thing
I think Ukraine is good in 2023 Ukraine
is going to win the war
what does wind look like that's
debatable but for sure Russia ain't
going to win it and I think Ukraine wins
it and it will be a terrible defeat uh
for Russia and suddenly things will get
back to normal and we'll be pouring
resources into Ukraine to help build it
I think inflation will come down much
more quickly than the forecasters say
just as it went up much more quickly
than the forecasters thought indeed if
you begin to look at uh towards the end
of 2024 or 25 you begin to see deflation
beginning to take a grip but for a while
as inflation plummets it'll make us feel
better it'll raise our living sons and
will come out on the cost of living and
a crisis and if people start to spend
more again then growth returns to the
economy so I don't despair you know both
as journalists and uh as politicians
we find it very hard to to discern when
the trend we're living through comes to
an end and we kind of act as if trees
grow to the sky that you know inflation
is now double digit is always going to
be double digits where uh we've got no
growth we're going to have no growth for
the foreseeable future I think there'll
be quite a dramatic turnaround led by
America uh in in the economic Outlook
and that so I am more positive on the
economic Outlook in as 2023 proceeds
we're heading into recession there's no
doubt about that but I don't think it's
going to be that deep all that long and
I think as prices start to fall more
quickly than the forecasters thing can
you really begin to see a bit of that in
America now as well the the economic
optimism will return so I don't think
there's a need for Endless Gloom however
much some people need to feel they
should be an endless Gloom just to keep
them happy
thank you Andrew you've cheered me up
which is almost impossible at the moment
uh Lionel what gives you hope
um I've been much cheered by what's been
going on in China
um on on multiple levels I mean it is
satisfying as someone who has opposed
covid lockdowns from the very beginning
to see uh the that policy taken to the
Max and to see it fail it doesn't work
and lockdown came from China and it's
dying in China it's also a relief to see
the Chinese people
be able to draw a line and say enough is
enough
I think we in the west often
write the Chinese off is just hopelessly
compliant and they'll do whatever
they're told they've been turned into
little automatons but they're not
and uh and you know they suffer under a
huge amount of control and oppression
and and someone is always watching them
I don't feel envious
but there have been a lot of people who
have now stuck their necks out and and
even in defiance of such would be
absolute control I'll say we're not
taking this anymore and I I think that's
a really good sign so it's it's good for
uh the spectacle uh uh internationally
of a highly destructive uh response to
disease it's it's good that it it looks
bad I was
amused how many Western media Outlets
responded to the Chinese protests so
it's like oh of course this you know
this policy is terrible it doesn't work
where were you two years ago you
bastards oh
and I I also think that what's going on
in Iran is is is cheerful I mean amid
amidst a lot of horror I mean they're
they're now starting to execute
protesters but this is again this is a
it's mostly young women who will not
take it anymore
and and
um I think that uh it's it's been well
observed that the left and the West
doesn't seem remotely interested which
is bizarre I mean when you think about
well isn't this the ultimate me too
patriarchy
um where where you have to go around you
know
in a bin liner I mean it's it
it's a horribly repressive regime for
for women in particular and it's bizarre
to me that the women's movement in the
west is not interested
but I'm interested and and I really wish
them the best I mean I am a little
skeptical because so many of these
revolutions come to nothing think the
Arab Spring but but before
this one also comes to nothing I'm going
to be optimistic
well I can't think of a better note to
end it on uh human Freedom will always
flourish uh Andrew Neil and Lionel
Shriver thank you very much and a very
happy Christmas to you both thank you
Merry Christmas to you too
[Music]